Hey, Youtubers!  It's Charlie.
So they finally released the official version of the Ant-Man
post credits scene, so I thought it was time to talk about
Captain America: Civil War.  We have a trailer coming up,
so here's the clip just in case you haven't seen it,
then we're gonna break it down.
[abs]
This would've been a lot easier a week ago.
If we call Tony...
No, he won't believe us.
Even if he did...
Who knows if the Accords will let him help?
We're on our own.
Maybe not.
I know a guy.
So there are really like two big things going on here.
One, you have Ant-Man officially joining Team Cap,
(He's like a total fangirl.  It's the most adorable thing ever.)
and then you have them finding Bucky.  When they say
"This would've been easier last week,"
they're talking about the government taking a huge
dump on superheroes.
A bunch of information about all the shady stuff that's
been going on goes public, so everybody knows that
the Winter Soldier is Bucky, and he's a total dirtbag.
So Cap wants to save his friend, but he can't take him
out in public because they'll lynch him.
Of course, the head of that mob is Tony Stark.
He basically draws the line in the sand.
Like, "We need to keep these superheroes above board.
They have to be registered.  They have to be monitored."
Cap thinks that that's a big violation of civil liberties,
so of course, there you have your civil war.
Unofficially, it's like "Avengers 2.5" just because so many
of the Avengers are in the movie.
The biggest notable absence that we know about is Thor.
Now he's gonna be dealing with what's going on with
Asgard during Thor: Ragnarok.
Even though that movie isn't coming out for a while,
in the timeline, it picks up relatively close to where
Civil War is happening.  So that's why he's not around
when this is going down.
But, there's also the Hulk which is now confirmed to be
in Thor: Ragnarok, so he's probably only gonna be
mentioned in passing during Civil War.
They, they said that there was just like too many people
in Civil War for Hulk to make it in.
Originally, Mark Ruffalo was supposed to have a spot.
I guess he doesn't now.  Either way, there are so many
people in the movie, you won't notice.
The weird thing about Marvel Studios when it comes to
Civil War is that originally they were gonna do a very
different story, but then they got Spider-Man,
so it started to move closer and closer to comic book Civil War.
Now obviously there are still gonna be a lot of
differences because almost every character that Marvel
owns was part of comic book Civil War,
and Marvel Studios can't put them all in the movie
because Fox owns a bunch of those.  Sony owns a
bunch of the other characters, too.
Spider-Man and Scarlett Witch are the exceptions,
but Scarlett Witch and Vision are definitely in the movie.
I've already done a video on what the teams are
supposed to be, so I'll put a link for that in the description.
But I know a lot of you are asking, "What about TV shows?
What about the NETFLIX shows?"
Like, "Is Daredevil gonna show up in Civil War?"
As far as we know, that is not gonna be the case.
Agents of Shield always does some kind of crossover.
Hopefully, it'll be more exciting than the Avengers: Age of Ultron crossover.
That, that was kind of a disappointment, so we'll see.
I'm not expecting Coulson to show up in the movies
anytime soon, especially after Joss Whedon is like,
"Yeah, for all intensive purposes, Coulson is still dead
in the movies."  The TV shows always kinda have to
dance between the movies' raindrops.
But speaking of TV shows, there is so much happening
this week.  Jessica Jones is dropping, all 13 episodes
are dropping on Friday.
Usually that happens at midnight.  I'm gonna do
as many videos as I can for episodes.  I don't know if
I'll be able to do a video for every single episode,
so I might have to do like one video for every two episodes
just to get them all out, but I'll try and get all of my
Jessica Jones episode videos out within like a one week span.
So I should at least post a Jessica Jones video like
once every two days.  I mean it just depends on how
fast I get through them all.
We also just found out that Agent Carter season 2
is gonna premiere Tuesday, January 5th,
so you start the year off right doing what Peggy says.
All the characters are going to Las Angeles, like Peggy's
gonna be based in Las Angeles.  Howard Stark buys
a movie studio.  They're gonna have Madame Masque,
a bunch more comic book characters.
It's gonna be awesome.
And the cool thing about Agent Carter that's different
from Agents of Shield is that Marvel Studios, like the
movie people, help make Agent Carter.  They don't do
that for Agents of Shield.  Agents of Shield is made by ABC Studios.
Kevin Feige himself actually helped make some
Agent Carter season 1 episodes, so they just take a lot
of extra care with that show, which is why it looks fantastic.
We'll talk more about Agent Carter later in the year,
but everybody asking about the Civil War trailer,
Marvel has already confirmed that they're gonna drop it
with Star Wars: The Force Awakens, and when they say
the trailer is gonna drop with Star Wars, they're talking
about the US release date.  There are a lot of countries
where Star Wars is being released a little bit earlier,
like a couple days earlier.  I'm talking about the US
release on the 18th.
So either the trailer is gonna drop during that week,
like say on Tuesday the 15th, or it's gonna drop on the
actual day that Star Wars drops, on Friday the 18th.
So either way, Civil War trailer that week,
and if you didn't see, the X-Men trailer is totally jumping
in the dogpile.  Fox is dropping the official X-Men: Apocalypse
trailer on that same day!
So there is a shit ton of stuff happening in December.
Don't worry, like if you're not good with dates, you're not
good with scheduling stuff, whenever I start shouting
about stuff, you'll know it's happening.
Like whenever it starts going down, I will start freaking out.
It'll be awesome.
Later tonight, I'm working on a new Game of Thrones
video, then we have a new Gotham.
Most of the rest of this week is gonna be a pretty
normal week, with the exception of Jessica Jones on Friday.
So while you guys wait for everything to post,
You can click here for all my Captain America: Civil War videos,
and you can click here for all of my Jessica Jones videos.
Thank you so much for watching!
Everybody, let's high five.
I'll see you guys tonight.